of course the problem with these people
is they lie about everything they are so
deep in the lives they cannot stop lying
all they've got are lies they are in the
bottomless pit of lying and when you are
in that bottomless pit where there is no
bottom you must lie constantly to not
just fall into the abyss here is black
lesbian Kareem Jean-Pierre lying and
when we look at where we are
economically and we are in a strong uh
we are stronger economically than we
have been uh in history when you look at
the unemployment numbers at 3.6 percent
uh when you look at the jobs numbers
more than 8.7 million of new jobs
created it's just it's such lies that
everyone knows it's live where did those
jobs come from lady is it because there
are gajillion new companies that are all
thriving right now or is it because you
forced all of these people out of work
uh well one of my favorite meme makers
online this guy mazemore uh he had a
funnier version of that and when we look
at where we are economically and we are
in a strong we are stronger economically
than we have been in history
the internet's pretty good when you want
it to be